hi I'm sue big uns and as a privileged
to talk to Lee Hartwell today about his
pioneering work in understanding the
regulation
cell-cycle this of course led to the
Nobel Prize in Physiology or medicine in
2001 just for background I want to
remind everyone that the cell cycle is
an ordered process where the genome and
organelles are duplicated and accurately
partitioned into daughter cells and it's
really one of the most fundamental
things for all organisms by studying the
morphology of temperature-sensitive
mutants in yeast ly heart will identify
many of the key regulators of the cell
cycle his seminal discoveries included
identifying the cell division cycle or
CDC genes that are now known to be
universal regulators of the cell cycle
in organisms from yeast to frogs to
humans perhaps the best-known of these
genes is CDC 28 which is the master
regulatory kinase that controls the
progression of cells through the start
of the cell cycle Hartwell is also
credited for discovering cell cycle
checkpoints such as the DNA damage
checkpoint checkpoints are signals that
let the cell know if a step in the cell
cycle is not completed and then generate
a silikal arrest and Lee it's really fun
to be talking here in Seattle where you
did your groundbreaking work that led to
the Nobel Prize thanks for doing this my
pleasure so to get started Lee can you
tell us what got you started or
interested in science
Oh going back a long ways I think the
turning point for me was in high school
I hadn't been a very serious student but
I had a great physics teacher who
challenged me with hard problems to take
home and work on and I just looked back
on that as a turning point where I got
interested in science
what about biology when did you get
interested in biology not until I was in
Caltech as a sophomore I took a I was
always planning to be a physics major
and I took a course from James Bond ER
and it was supposed to be sort of a
biology general biology course but as I
remembered he spent the entire semester
ranting and raving about how great DNA
so this was about 1957 or so so it was
only a few years after the structure of
DNA had been discovered and he was so
exciting I just changed my major on the
spot and became a biologist hmm great
what inspired you to work on the cell
cycle
well I looking back I think that
somewhere I gained the perspective that
scientists ask big questions I suppose
that I got that idea at Caltech but
after I'd gotten my graduate PhD and was
deciding where to go for a postdoc and
thinking about what I wanted to work on
I chose cell division because as you say
it's very fundamental to biology and it
seemed like almost nothing was known
about it so that that seemed like an
interesting direction to go in and do
you want to tell us a little bit about
the CDC screen well let me first just
mention how we got into yeast yeah I was
gonna ask that question everyone had
asked that question why yeast yeah I
wrote a grant to do cell division
studies in mammalian cells as I had been
doing but I knew I didn't want to do
that and I was really frustrated about
what to do and I had about a period of
about three months where the equipment
I'd ordered was on coming but not
arrived yet when I just had time to
think and I remember talking to one of
my colleagues about this dan wolf he was
from Dell Brooks group at Caltech I had
worked in Dell Brooks group as an
undergraduate and he said well why don't
you take it look for a simpler organism
and that was the key for me and I
immediately went to the library and
started scouring for eukaryotic cells
where you could do genetics and cell
physiology and so that's how I came to
yeast
and was really because of a frustration
with what I couldn't do with animals and
so that leads me to wonder about looking
for temperature-sensitive mutants why
did you make that decision well I wanted
the essential genes and I had as an
undergraduate
as I said worked in Del books group with
Bob Edgar and Bob Edgar did a beautiful
piece of work on how t4 virus is put
together 150 proteins or so getting
mutations in genes that were part of the
structure of the virus now the problem
is a mutant that's defective in an
essential function for the organism is
dead and so you have to make them
conditional so they'll grow under one
condition but not under another and Bob
had used temperature-sensitive mutants
and Horowitz at Caltech very early in
genetics had gotten
temperature-sensitive mutants in the
Ross Perot so I knew about that
conditional phenomenon and so that was
the obvious way to go now why don't you
tell us the story about morphologies and
how you what you were looking for and
how you went about that when I moved to
the University of Washington the
genetics department there was an
undergraduate in the laboratory there
Brian Reed who is now at the Fred
Hutchinson Cancer Center studying
esophageal cancer and I suggested to
Brian that he looked at some mutants
that formed odd morphologies and the
question was once you there was some
really interesting work in Paramecium
that showed that if you surgically
changed the surface of the cell that was
inherited and so that was very
interesting some kind of struck
girl inheritance and the surface so we
had mutants that at a high temperature
became morphologically abnormal and I
suggested to Brian that he looked to see
if that was inherited so he would shift
him the high temperature and then shift
him back down to low temperature and it
turned out it wasn't in heritage but
then we he got interested in the
question well how do they go from
abnormal to normal and so he started
taking pictures of them in the
microscope and as I remember it
immediately we realized how much
information there was in these
photographs about the cell cycle and
started then screening all of our
mutants for their morphological changes
when we shifted the temperature so
another question I had is how did you
order the cell cycle using your immunes
well the the mutants provided some order
because for example there were mutants
that didn't bud
there were mutants that didn't make DNA
and then everything else stopped there
were mutants that didn't divide the new
and made DNA but didn't divide the
nucleus and and different steps around
the cell cycle so in in principle what
the mutants told us was that there's
basically two cycles when the cell
passes the commitment to division that
we called start the nuclear cycle is one
series of events the DNA synthesis and
the division of the nucleus and another
series of events has to do with the cell
surface which is the formation of the
bud and then eventually the division of
the cell wall at the vision time and at
least two things two pathways have to
hook up at the end so the the pathways
and events order of events was largely
determined by the phenotypes of the
mutants
can you explain sort of the two big
models you're trying to distinguish
between in terms of the regulation of
this
cycle ie the substrate model versus a
timing model so when the cell stopped in
the cell cycle because something hasn't
been completed the question becomes why
they stopped so let's say a cell can't
make its DNA why does the cell stop with
the chromosomes not separated why
doesn't it just go ahead and try to
separate the chromosomes and get
incomplete chromosomes and then die why
does it stirs it no how does the mitotic
spindle know that the DNA is incomplete
so that was the question and and and
there's sort of two ways to think about
this one is that the DNA is part of the
mitotic spindle and if it's not complete
then the spindle just can't function so
that's sort of the substrate model the
other model is that there's signals in
the cell the cell has a communication
system that tells it what's happening
and what hasn't happened and that when
the DNA isn't replicated a signal is
sent to the mitotic spindle that says
wait so that's the other model so which
one did you discover was correct so yes
so that was a story that begins with a
postdoctoral fellow named Ted Weinert
and Ted wanted to study regulation and
as we were discussing what regulation
might mean I had collected a bunch of
radiation sensitive mutants in the
freezer and so I got him out and Ted
looked at him and it turned out that I
think it was just a few days that he
discovered that some of the radiation
sensitive mucus when you x-ray them
arrest cell-cycle so and they just stay
arrested whereas the normal cell would
arrest repair and then go on
so these mutants were defective in the
repair process but there were other
mutants that just didn't stop dividing
they just kept dividing and produced
dead colonies and so we realized that
these were defective in the signaling
and that there was a signal that told
the cell when there were breaks in DNA
right and you define this as a
checkpoint yeah and do you want to say a
little bit more about what you view the
definition of a checkpoint as well we
tried to define it relatively clearly as
as something which is is needed to
arrest division when something goes
wrong at the time when you discovered
this checkpoint did you think that there
might be other checkpoints for other
cellular processes we certainly wondered
that and I think over the years a lot
more have been discovered and so you
know one of the I think really
fundamental principles about biology
that fascinates me is the tremendous
accuracy of biological processes so
yeast cells lose a chromosome about once
in a hundred thousand divisions that's
remarkably precise reproducible
especially when you watch mitosis and
see the chromosomes jiggling around and
everything you wonder how they keep
track of them and and I suspect that's
true for all kinds of cellular processes
that normally we can't measure the
accuracy because it is so accurate and
and so the the extent to which evolution
has
driven the accuracy of biological
processes is really enormous and it I
think it must mean that for most things
that go on in biology there's the basic
machinery there are things which repair
the basic machinery when it gets in
trouble and there are things that
coordinate that repair with everything
else that's going on and we probably
only know the tip of the iceberg yet in
terms of cell biology CDC 28 is the most
famous conserved cell cycle molecule
probably since um that was in large part
with winning the Nobel Prize with Tim
hunt and Paul nurses contributions what
did you think before we knew what that
what that protein did did you have a
feeling what you thought that molecule
would end up being no I I really didn't
think in terms of biochemistry I I
wasn't interested in biochemistry it's
funny but I was just much more
interested in the order and and
regulation of events and in cell cycle
but it's really interesting that before
that story broke Fischer and Krebs who
were had gotten the Nobel Prize for
protein phosphorylation came to me and
said and we had a meeting and they
wanted to know whether I thought kinase
could play any role in the cell cycle
and I said well you know I just don't
know you know but it was interesting
because that was actually the right
guess and CDC 28 turned out to be a
kinase and their suspicions were correct
we now know that many of the CDC genes
are conserved was it a surprise to you
how many were conserved now now that we
know what they all are we're more
concerned than you thought less I think
in general
biology has surprised us all in the
degree of conservation at the molecular
level and we're even seeing so we so the
answer is yes for me it surprised me I
was just hoping that cell division in
yeast would be enough like mammalian
cells to be a useful model and only
after genes were cloned and sequenced
and various things and did we find out
how conserved they are I think it's
something like 50% of yeast genes can be
complemented by human proteins I think
it's amazing what you are able to learn
given how little you could really
measure now we have so many tools to to
know what's happening to different
structures in the cell and you were
really limited to just looking at
budding and the nuclear position I'm
curious if there was at the time one
extra thing you could have seen or one
tool you could have had what would you
have chosen what would have given you
the most information that you couldn't
get at that time well we actually had
that experience in that when we first
learned to do photo microscopy and could
look at the morphology of the cells and
pick out those that looked like they
might be cell cycle mutants we didn't
know what was going on inside the cell
so we had to be able to see the nucleus
and at that time that was very difficult
to sustain the cells to see the nucleus
there was only one guy who could really
do it his name was Robin al and it
turned out there was a some
international meeting and he was coming
to Seattle and I got in touch with him
and asked him if he'd come to the lab a
day ahead and show us how to see nuclei
and stain them and he did and so then we
were able to verify that the mutants
that look like cell division mutants
were actually defective in in nuclear
division as well what was so hard about
getting the nuclear staining to work
it was just a tricky because the amount
of DNA is so small in the yeast and
you're trying to stain the DNA and
there's a hundred times as much RNA as
there is DNA and so it's it's hard to
get the staining conditions just right
so you can see that DNA so if there
could have been one more structure you
could see what would you have chosen at
the time oh well that's an interesting
story too now that you bring it up is my
colleague Brett Byers was in the
genetics department and I went to him at
one time and said well we've got all
these mutants we should you know look at
their detailed three-dimensional
structure do thin sections and
reconstruct the cell and everything and
he looked at me and he said there's only
one thing of interest and that's the
spindle and I said ok so he started
looking at the spindle on electron
microscopy and found that some mutants
were defective in making the pole
duplicate and some others were defective
and forming the spindle you mentioned
earlier and in your Nobel lecture as
well that when he started your lab you
didn't really have a plan of what you
were gonna work on and this is so
different than how things work today
where people have to have early and
well-developed
research proposals to get a job and they
know exactly what they're going to work
on and I'm just curious if you think
this change actually hinders creativity
or if this is a good change
I think the present system does hinder
creativity I think that opening up new
fields requires a long incubation period
I just recently experienced that myself
because the last decade I've been
interested in education and and it's
taken me ten years to sort of figure out
what I want to do there and
and and the current system just doesn't
allow students to go beyond their
immediate experience so you can keep
extending what what's already going on
and what's interesting and productive
but to really start something new is is
very hard to do in the current
environment established labs can do it
if they have a little bit of leeway to
try something new for a year or
something but that in the whole system
of you know counting publications and
impact factors and grants and all the
things I think the best system for
sponsoring science was the old system at
the MRC in England which doesn't exist
anymore
MRC exist but the system doesn't exist
they've adopted the American system
unfortunately but their scientists used
to be given a budget yearly that would
support themselves and a technician and
maybe a graduate student or two and that
was guaranteed regardless of whether
they produced anything or not and then
they could get grants on top of that but
I think that basic level of stability
allowed some people to do very creative
things and take five years to do it
before they published
you